[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Justin's
in Houston Texas Justin welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hello Dave thank you for taking my call
sure
um I was wondering about taking a loan
out for home repairs for the end goal
being to sell the home and I I know that
uh that is as bad but uh the situation
is that I have two elderly relatives
with uh
um
fixed income and uh the houses that they
have fortunately are completely paid off
the issue is that they they have like us
the significant damages to the
foundation to revolve a lot of it
they're safe to live in
um but I was thinking perhaps if there's
some uh if an equity loan could be taken
out against it in order to fix those
significant issues and then sell off
those houses so that they can eventually
live in like a smaller place like a
condominium or a townhouse where uh they
wouldn't be burdened by the property
taxes that these houses are in
um if that would be acceptable in your
opinion
I would not do that no
because that's always with a story with
debt your story only works if it works
but I've been there when it doesn't work
like when these people with hardly any
income have a home equity loan the house
won't sell and the interest rates go
through the roof did you notice interest
rates have been rising
and now they're sitting there trapped oh
now they get foreclosed on
that's the people I've met
okay the debt plan only works when it
works and it hardly ever works because
life ever hardly ever works exactly the
way you map it out in your head
so yeah if everything worked exactly
like you said would that work yeah it
would work but it doesn't it's not how
life works the contractor screws them
doing the basement repairs
now they've got all the debt and the
repairs still aren't quite done so but
they borrowed all they can borrow now
they're trapped with a partially
completed construction project oh and
then the interest rates go up and then
one of them Falls ill
yeah this is this is this is how real
life unfolds here
so why wouldn't you just sell the houses
out right right now as is as is and get
the cash
well uh my concern is that the damage
are such that uh that the amount that
the houses would sell for would be
significantly less than that they could
potentially get yeah well that's true
but they're not in the real estate
investment business they're in the broke
old people business
yes that's correct and and that was like
in my my ideal vision is that they could
get as much money for their houses to be
able to sustain uh their retirement
they're in their 80s do you have any
money
uh I I do but uh not much money do you
have
um I have around my wife and I have
around
98k in our uh retirement accounts
um and then and um yeah that's and we we
have no debt we've been very blessed so
you don't you don't have the money to
give them for this do you
no sir okay
you are a kind person Justin trying to
do something good for your grandma
grandpa or your uncle or aunt or whoever
it is and um but you're getting ready to
create a bigger mess because you don't
see all the unintended things that could
come about here that actually likely are
more likely than the um scenario that
you've laid out in your head that's what
I'm trying to describe to you so yeah I
would get with uh go to Ramsay Solutions
and click on Ramsay trusted for real
estate and get an agent to come over
there and tell them hey help me with
this because I don't want these people
have to give these houses away but they
simply don't have the money to fix them
and how can we get an investor in here
to give top dollar as is as John was
suggesting because that's where this
needs to go man I mean my grandparents
did the exact thing we're talking about
here the neighborhood they they were in
in the same city there in Houston was
starting to be gentrified and
they had some major work they need to be
done on the foundation some major work
need to be on the driveway they just
sold the house the guy came up and wrote
him a check in the driveway hand him a
check for the I mean it was it was
transaction yeah and because that's not
it's not as much as if it had been fixed
up that's right that's what his point is
about that but we're not in the house
flipping business that's right that's
right that wasn't there that wasn't
their game to play and they may have had
to go to a different nursing home or
whatever but they did they I mean it's
just not the business we're in you know
broke 70 year olds don't do rehabs for
flips
that's what it amounts to especially on
margin especially especially when you're
borrowing a home equity loan on a paid
for a house it's just
um and that's that's being cold but
really this is the the actual fact of
what we're facing now how do we deal how
do we walk through it yeah well I'm uh
the the so I don't want them to have to
sell their house so cheap that decision
was made years ago when they didn't
bother to keep the maintenance up
now we're just having to execute the
decision
that's when they gave up that Equity was
when they didn't do the maintenance
years ago and they didn't take care of
their money so that they could but they
chose to buy crystal houses which is
very instead of fixing up the one yeah
exactly exactly so yeah get get with a
Ramsey uh trusted real estate agent
there there's a bunch of really good
ones in Houston somebody will help you
try to get this and try to help get
these folks out of this because bless
their hearts they're they're in a mess
of their own making but they're in a
mess and we don't want to make the mess
bigger which is what debt does
so
yeah the um the you know I I actually
100 years ago it feels like now I was in
a a Bible study and from a Christian or
spiritual perspective or a Biblical
perspective when you this guy was
pointing out it's not words we use
anymore because it's so long ago but he
said when you borrow you are presuming
and there's all kinds of scriptures
against presuming presumption don't
presume you know that the Lord don't
presume upon something you can't control
as as like the future
you know because who the cred knows
you're going to have a fouchy quarantine
I mean who the crud knows you know
apparently fauci did but the rest of us
did right I mean it's just like wow so
this is and hey I grew up in the house
of somebody who worked at Enron don't
tell me no my business is secure no my
company is doing great
um like it just it's life we wouldn't
have jobs if if life didn't turn that
way man yeah if it turned out the way
you thought it was going to turn out
every time no nobody would be calling
and if you if you want to count on one
thing over the next 24 months while we
uh go through the presidential cycle
again it's going to get chaotic out
there so I wouldn't borrow imagine